so after the video this week showing
migrants sleeping in the Boston Logan
Airport one Georgia state senator
captures new video showing migrants
inside a hidden room at the Atlanta
airport
watch yeah transporting anybody anywhere
yeah we're all getting them plac to to
where they need to be yeah so these are
just
uh recently documented Travelers getting
released from Ice getting to where they
need to be just let me let me get a
video if you don't uh actually you
cannot get a video you cannot get a
video no you're not allowed you're not
allowed you're done did you hear that
documented Travelers joining us right
now Georgia state senator colon Moore so
I'm confused because I'm going to read
this statement later on in in the
segment but the person that you were
speaking to said that they were
documented and we know that they were
illegal
right yeah we uh you know we got a
whistleblower uh who gave us a tip about
this hidden room and uh I had a full
team there with some different cameras
in different places said on Monday and
Tuesday nights there's just an influx of
these people who come through the
airport kind of when the uh the traffic
is much lower at the airport uh they
were in a hidden room I was talking to
an Atlanta Police Department
investigator yesterday there are
absolutely no cameras in this area of
the airport um if you watch another part
of the video you'll see that there's
some barricades and some caution tape
before you get there it kind of looks
like a con construction zone if you will
so can you explain to me because you
know Airport's supposed to be one of the
most secured locations there's cameras
everywhere is this inside of the
terminals or outside of the terminals th
this is uh I believe it's technically
the third floor but it appears as if
it's the second floor in the domestic
terminal uh our whistleblower says they
walk right out of the gates and then
they're escorted into this room those
people in that room though they were
waiting to be booked to flights all
across the United States uh we were also
getting video of migrants who were just
walking out onto the Streets of Atlanta
and who's guarding the
door so there was a US Army soldier
there at the door the guy who says
you're done uh he is a United States
soldier uh we we still not sure exactly
what his role was there uh but he was
sitting right next to the door and uh
basically assaulted me in order to take
the phone and try you know to get rid of
the footage uh I was able to recover the
phone and and that's the footage you see
there this is crazy what's going on here
I don't know you know there's a lot of
questions to be answered I hope the
Georgia Senate will Flex it subpoena
Authority and uh start bringing some
folks from the airport in and getting
answers to these questions have you yet
uh been able to get in contact with
Governor km about this I can't I can
just imagine that he's not too happy
about what's going on I I think this is
the largest airport in the nation yeah
it is it's the busiest airport in the
world um the governor Kemp and I are a
lot of odds on this issue uh with with
with the Fon Willis issue in Georgia we
haven't spoken I know people in my
district have sent him text messages uh
he's kind of passed the buck and said
this is a federal issue I certainly wish
we were sending State resources down to
the Southwest border like Governor Ronda
Santa says what do you want to see done
right now when it comes to this
airport I I want to see these people not
be able to leave the airport uh you know
the city of Atlanta controls the Atlanta
airport uh they ought to be housing
these people here until we can figure
out uh things going forward well Senator
the Governor comes on our show we we
hope that he'll come back and tell us
exactly what he knows about this as well
I just want to read the statement uh
from Atlanta International Airport this
is what they said ATL works with
libertad uh volunteers to provide
assistance to immigrants during their
travel immigrants I thought they were
documented team libertad is a nonprofit
that has worked at ATL since 2020 and
there are no military or other law
enforcement agencies in involved in this
effort immigrants are never housed in
the airport uh state senator we're going
to follow this we appreciate you coming
on this morning yeah thanks for having
me some shady business going on we'll
get to the bottom of it thanks Senator
thank
you over to you asy he's going to get a
lot of votes in the next election proud
of him for going to do that because
that's not easy to do great interview
Lawrence I'm Steve duy I'm Brian kilme
and I'm Angley aart and click here to
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube page
to catch our Hott interviews and most
compelling
analysis